welcome to the all-new relaunched
rebranded and rebooted Reuben report as
of this episode right the second we now
begin our journey as a fully fan funded
show thanks to you guys just about a
month ago I announced that we were
packing up moving on from our RTV and
creating our very own production company
my team of amira David and I have worked
incredibly hard to create our fan
funding campaign and make it a reality
so that we could go totally independent
when I went to sleep the night before
the campaign launched I had no idea if
my career was about to end or if we were
just gonna be at the beginning once
again well thanks to about 3000 of you
who have taken a chance on me and on us
the future of this show and the
conversations we're having about big
ideas and free speech are looking
incredibly bright because of all of you
who put your money where your keyboard
is the 18 years I've spent on my career
have come to fruition right now my own
voice has been crystallized and I now
have total ownership over a forum to
share the ideas I care about most the
last month in which I also managed to
turn 40 has been the most rewarding
exhilarating and simultaneously
inspiring time of my life so while I've
said it before and I'll say it many
times again thank you to all of you who
heard me and who rose up to the occasion
without a doubt the best part of the
past month has been connecting with
literally thousands of you the viewers
in one form or another via email
Facebook periscope Twitter Skype or face
to face I've not only talked to you but
I've listened and learned from you as
well within four days of our fan funding
campaign on patreon we hit the initial
goal of 20,000 a month allowing us to
have the monthly budget not only to
continue the Rubin report but to also go
above and beyond our current workload we
now are in a studio in which we can do
more shows eventually start live
streaming episodes and much more we also
received an outpouring of donations from
you guys to our PayPal account which
helped us buy our new equipment and set
and which I'm incredibly excited to
finally be able to share with you today
you didn't contribute or you couldn't
contribute it's all good but you should
know that the 3,000 people who did
contribute are directly the reason we're
back in action right now if you shared
our message on social media told family
or friends about us or even just clicked
play on one of our videos at the Apple
Store I thank you as well
sharing our message is an incredibly
important piece of this whole thing
beyond the 3,000 donors and patrons
though so many of you guys reached out
to us offering services professional
services personal services whatever it
was you guys were offering to edit to
make graphics to compose music to hang
lights and so much more and for all of
those who offer to work for us we've got
all the messages set aside and I promise
you that we're gonna circle back once we
get the launch fully complete and see
where we're at what was clear to me more
than anything during this time is that
the issues that I care about most of
honest conversation big ideas and free
speech aren't just concepts but are
real-world events when you put them into
action as my life has changed with this
show so have many of yours you're having
the same conversations at home and at
school and at work you're offering your
services and support because you care
about the same things that I care about
that to me is how you change the world I
can't really explain what it's like to
receive such an outpouring of support
for the show that I do waking up to
dozens of emails from people all over
the world every day telling you that
they believe in your message is an
incredible feeling as I've said to many
of you privately what we're doing here
has now become bigger than me or this
show everything that the Rubin report
has been about since we launched in
September seems to be coming to a head
right now our politics are more afraid
than ever our conversations seem dumber
than ever before we shout down those we
disagree with that's becoming the norm
and our need to find some truth that
through the endless sea of noise has
never been greater this has been my
focus since we started and clearly it's
time for us all to double down on that
mission thanks to our monthly patrons I
won't have to make corporate deals I
don't want to make and never have to
enter partnerships that could confuse or
negate this message you've given us the
runway to do the show as we see fit
without worrying if the lights will go
on tomorrow now not only do we know that
they'll go on but we
know that the show can grow exactly as
we wanted to while never wavering from
our commitment to real dialogue and
honest conversation
if you've donated on patreon or PayPal
whether it was a dollar or $500 you can
now consider yourself a producer of the
reuben report and by the way the
campaign still continues and the more it
grows the more content we can create so
yes Reuben report.com / donate is still
up and if you can't donate please just
help bring awareness to what we're doing
whether on social media or shouting from
the rooftops that's a little old-school
but I hear it can be quite effective
alright now it's on to season two of the
completely fan funded version of the
Reuben report in some ways it was kind
of tough figuring out who to get for the
first episode but all roads seem to lead
back to one person and that person just
so happens to be the same person who
season one started with way back last
September Sam Harris is one of the
clearest thinkers honest brokers and
logical debaters I know at the same time
he's become a poster child for the
battle against the regressive left no
matter what he says the usual clown car
of dishonest public figures come out to
manipulate his words trivialize his
arguments and lie about his intentions
never once have I heard Sam say he's
absolutely right and should be above
criticism but most of the criticism I
hear about him has little to do with
what he actually says or thinks and more
to do with the disingenuous motives of
those attacking him as I've said before
my political awakening was really
crystallized on that infamous night of
real time when Ben Affleck called Sam's
views gross and racist suddenly the onus
was on Sam and Bill Maher to prove they
weren't racist even though they were
nothing of the sort
what they did was stand up for true
universal freedoms despite the
uncomfortable conversation about
religion that it causes us to have
people often ask me if I hate Ben
Affleck but the truth is I actually
thank him for that moment if he hadn't
been so utterly ridiculous and exhibited
such childish thinking maybe my wake up
would have taken that much longer if
anything I hate Affleck for Batman vs
Superman but fortunately I fell asleep
through most of that garbage anyway the
point is I know that many
you also had your awakening around that
event and some of the other subsequent
events like Charlie Hebdo only a few
months later it wasn't just good ideas
that woke us up it was the necessary bad
ones to show us what was really going on
ironically Sam had been on real time
that night to promote his book waking up
a guide to spirituality without religion
subsequently after that Fiasco he spent
most of his book tour which was supposed
to be about finding inner peace
defending himself against charges of
racism maybe there's some kind of karma
in that but I'm pretty sure Sam doesn't
think so while we're gonna jump back
into the debate around Islam the
election and the left I intend to spend
much of our conversation focusing on
some of the other things that Sam cares
about including freewill spirituality
and the subject of his next book
artificial intelligence
I assume that by tomorrow he'll be
accused of being a robot a phob and a
robo cyst but that just comes with the
territory of being someone not afraid to
share their thoughts so one more time
though I know it won't be the last time
I want to humbly thank all of you for
your support I'm just one guy trying to
do what I think is right and you have
shown me that if you build it they will
talk so now we built it and it's time to
talk here we go